[Music]
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers I can tell Hulk gives
it away
[Music]
there's a new top no you've seen that
before
no with that skirt you should probably
stop staring story it's creepy though
too late
you guys are losers so to become an
Avenger are there like trials or any
movie just don't do anything I would do
and definitely don't do anything I
wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
that's not a hug that I'm just grabbing
the top layer all right good good luck
out there
listen I know school sucks
you still with us uh yeah yeah I know
you want to save the world
you're not ready yet you're the sweater
man no I'm not I'm not this is just a
costume this is for the ceiling stay
close to the ground stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing
treating me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
what is going on with you I'm sorry I'm
so busy I'm slamming don't mess with me
cuz I will kill you and everybody you
love